that's a tremendous philosophic
proposition
and the ultimate source of human freedom
[Music]
what what does it mean all men are
created equal when obviously by the way
they are not like look around the table
i'm old you're young boys and girls
large and small younger and older
you're just a baby aren't you yes he's
just awful he's just he's a precocious
sophomore his old christian here
so uh we're not equal right compare
children and dogs
the most important comparison by the way
in the entire academic world
key to understanding all nature is to
compare children
and dogs i don't like cats i don't
compare them
but children and dogs right and what is
it about the children and the dogs
you can raise them just about the same
way when they're young
but then at some point the children
start speaking and somehow they've
picked up on
how people act and how people interact
they talk
the specific thing they do see in my
family
the children are grown now and we have
these two boxers and they're really
great one of them's a three-legged dog
and he's the happiest dog we ever had
and the dogs are everywhere wherever we
are so you guys are all coming over to
my house for dinner and you will find
that you'll be dining with the dogs
and when we were raising the kids the
dogs were always there
and after about a year and a half the
kids started talking and the dogs never
did
and they they'd all heard exactly the
same things right
so this talking aristotle says that the
gift of speech
which is identical he claims
to reason or rationality they are the
same thing the argument
is when you are talking you are thinking
to yourself you are
thinking out loud and when you are
thinking you are talking to yourself
it's the same thing
now somehow this
capacity we have that makes us human
there's some
respect in which we are all created
equal and where i think that is
is this phenomenon of the dogs and the
kids
dogs at various times in their lives are
greatly preferable
to children right but they're not the
same kind of thing
else they would say so and they never do
right last night the dogs were talking
to us as dogs talk
right and aristotle says animals use
their voices to indicate pleasure and
pain
people speak to distinguish the just
from the unjust
right this whole thing
is a statement of the just and the
unjust
and it depends on this simple point
this is what all men are created equal
means you
are the king of england and you ride in
a golden carriage
and everybody salutes you and all fear
you
but you know when you were a year and a
half old
you started doing something that no
animal
has ever done and no one taught you to
do that
you just started doing it and it wasn't
because you were born
royal it's because you were born
human and so were we
it just means that and born in this
gift you see that we can speak
and therefore see that thing and that
thing is the same kind of thing
and it doesn't make any difference if
it's your kid or somebody else's
you can't treat it like a dog because it
is not a dog
and no king can treat it like a dog
because it is not a dog to him either
because it's not a dog
see once the ground is laid for that
then of course thomas jefferson can
write in the last serious letter he
wrote
some are not born with saddles on their
backs nor
others booted and spurred to ride them
by the grace of god
the king can rightly put a harness
on the horses that pull his carriage
but he can't do that to people unless
they volunteer
you see that's a tremendous
philosophic proposition and the
ultimate source of human freedom
and this by the way is the greatest
political statement of that
in all history
thank you for watching we hope you're
enjoying our highlight series and
invite you to explore all of hillsdale
college's online courses
they are free and for everyone who loves
to learn